yeah I mean I'm just a regular guy
that's never met a puppy Oh white people
have up to here I'm here to meet some
pup-pups I feel like I'm gonna just turn
into like a child that when I see them
since I haven't had a dog I feel like
something's missing in my life I am
concerned that I may have a puppy bug my
mustache I'm excited to meet any puppy
right now
these puppies are total divas right now
they just don't want to play with me
you didn't hit my mustache well I mean I
think everything's cuter when it's a
baby right
whoa this dip is so tiny
he's just so freaking cute I'm always
running away yeah he's gotta go look at
you so happy love this dog it's great
dog tell anyone about you missing
Oh bears got it now it kind of bonded
with these dogs like I don't know
they're just they're just so full of
life it makes me want to order one right
now it's it's like being with a little
friend I believe a pup pup will choose
me someday when the call is made it will
answer Oh like Shawn well these are not
big deal I'm so happy
good someone could love this you know oh
yeah baby and that is all